also unser finanzminister christian
lindner zu diesem sondervermögen von 100
milliarden euro für die bundeswehr und
bei uns im studio ist unser politik chef
jan schäfer der auch zugehört hat
natürlich jan 100 milliarden euro ich
krieg das irgendwie gar nicht über die
lippen weil das ist wirklich viel geld
ja für die bundeswehr jetzt also was
passiert genau mit dem geld 100
milliarden euro für die bundeswehr sind
eigentlich gar nicht so viel ist ihre
hohe summe keine frage aber wenn man
sich anschaut wie viel die bundeswehr
eigentlich pro jahr erhält aus dem
bundeshaushalt knapp 50 milliarden
bisschen und das war eigentlich zu wenig
dann sind die 100 milliarden am ende gar
nicht so viel vor allem weil 20 bis 25
milliarden so heißt es zumindest aus der
bundeswehr eigentlich für munition
allein drauf gehen müssen das bedeutet
in den nächsten fünf jahren also sollen
militärgerät gekauft werden sollen neue
panzer gekauft werden flugzeuge aber
natürlich auch munition wie die genaue
verteilung des geldes aussieht das steht
noch nicht fest klar ist und da hat sich
die union durchgesetzt dass zum beispiel
mittel für die zusätzlich ist cyber
sicherheit nicht aus diesem sogenannten
sondervermögen aus diesem neuen topf
kommen sollen sondern die sollen aus dem
laufenden haushalt finanziert werden da
fragt man sich dann aber auch wie soll
das ganze dann finanziert werden überall
wird ja jetzt mit millionen um sich
geworfen und der finanzminister
verspricht steuersenkungen
steuerreformen wer soll das ganze
bezahlen ihren am ende wir alle
und das hat christian lindner gerade
auch noch mal gesagt es geht um ein
sondervermögen das vieh hat er so schön
formuliert neben der schuldenbremse
steht also diese 100 milliarden die
werden komplett auch mit neuen schulden
finanziert und weil er es als
sondervermögen deklariert hat fließt es
also nicht mit in diese schuldenregel
die wir bisher kennen ein sondern steht
quasi daneben ist am ende aber nur ein
trick schulden sind schulden und sie
müssen irgendwann zurückgezahlt werde
aber du hast es ja gerade schon gesagt
es ging auch um das thema steuersenkung
und wir haben heute den dreifachen
lindner gerade eben in diesen paar
minuten gesehen den verteidiger den
verteidiger der s100 milliarden euro
sondervermögens den angreifer die er
ganz klar in forderung beispielsweise
vom arbeitsminister hubertus heil
zurückgewiesen hat die die im
sozialleistungen beim bürgergeld
stichwort bürgergeld auszuweiten hat er
gesagt ist nicht zu machen mit ihm er
will stattdessen eine
steuersenkung eine steuerreform und das
dritte das war der ja der appell ihrer
christian lindner der die
mineralölkonzerne aufgefordert hat beim
tank rabatt die steuersenkung die
beschlossen wurde auch wirklich an die
autofahrer weiter zu und da haben wir
besonders die ohren gespitzt weil das
könnte bedeuten dass ab mittwoch gar
nicht die preise sinken dann in
tankstellen das ist richtig das hat
christian lindner gerade gesagt robert
habeck hat sich auch ähnlich schon
geäußert die bundesregierung geht davon
aus dass nicht am mittwoch den ersten
juni um 0 uhr 0 1 an den zapfsäulen dann
alles billiger wird sondern sie gibt den
mineralölkonzernen noch ein paar tage
und dann wird es natürlich richtig
problematisch denn wenn wir am ersten
juni schon nicht sehen dass die
benzinpreise sehen ja wann sehen wir das
denn dann am vierten am 5 dann heißt es
wieder die benzinpreise auf dem
weltmarkt sind gestiegen der euro ist so
schwach wir wissen ja benzin wird in
dollar bezahlt das heißt je schwächer
der euro je stärker der dollar umso
teurer wird auch benzin also da gibt es
viele viele möglichkeiten für die
mineralölkonzerne sich dadurch zu
lavieren und an dieser energie
preissenkung ehrlich gesagt sich selbst
er die taschen voll zu machen als die
der autofahrer und deshalb hat
wahrscheinlich christian lindner dann
auch noch mal kurz den seitenhieb
gemacht und gesagt ich wollte diese
lösung gar nicht wollte dass ein
italienischer modell und jetzt soll er
habe ich mal damit beschäftigen
dankeschön vielen dank